[Music]
hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
look it's no secret that Rainbow six
siege has been home to some pretty
broken operators whether it's blitz with
his flashbang shield or maestro with his
scuba helmet that shoots laser beams
there's a myriad of characters who are
both blatantly imbalanced and downright
rage inducing how does that hit me dude
what the [ __ ]
I'd really hear it attached to the
wallets let's have a two second delay so
we thought why not rank them now we
present to you the top ten broken
operators in the history of Rainbow six
siege kicking off our list is everyone's
favorite stalker pulse this operator is
[ __ ] you know it I know it and he
knows it just look at that [ __ ] smirk
prior to patch 4.1 you could switch from
pulses cardiac censor to his primary in
half the time instead of having to wait
for pulse to close the sensor down you
can actually just weapon swap and voila
there you go you got your shotgun and
good to go
considering this was back when shotguns
were actually good the super fast switch
time made pulse an absolute juggernaut
oh and let's not forget pulses signature
c4 through the floor trick which with an
even faster switch time became nearly
impossible to evade coming in at number
nine is present-day echo time to be
efficient and kinda lazy for starters
his yoke I can gather Intel disorient
attackers and deny plants while they're
going down youkai drone though from Leon
will deny the plant it has an unlimited
number of charges and to top it all off
he gets two of them step one lay down
step
to get on your drone and gather Intel
step 3 get up and shoot them this step 4
lay the hell back down then there's his
ACOG primary which despite being
suppressed actually boasts a higher
damage output than the mp5s wielded by
both doc and rook guess what
echoes gun does a higher damage per
second than either rook or Doc's echoes
gun is actually a better gun and has a
suppressor please explain the logic
behind that one Ubisoft you could still
get this plant down but the youkai drone
is probably gonna have something else to
say about that is it's coming up on um
right now only three seconds left it's
might be bad timing for fabien but it
also might be the clutch as now Redeemer
is stuck in the plant and he's gonna get
eliminated from fabien taking the 8th
spot on our list is miss sad a maestro
himself pizza time
ah maestro while not broken per se he is
arguably the strongest operator in all
of siege no damage done ii will connect
though from fat-faced this astro math
fine another you know with a double kill
you know with a triple his nearly
indestructible evil eyes can destroy
utility spot looming attackers through
smoke and well shoot [ __ ] laser beams
at anything that moves full king laser
sights the thing is it doesn't stop
there his 80 bullet LMG is stronger than
most attacker weapons has an ACOG and
he's free to create as many rotation
holes as he pleases with his pistol
since it's basically a shotgun seriously
why wouldn't you pick this operator
plant going down and Redeemer will go
for two big kills for a jammer three oh
my goodness puts himself at a 1v1
defuser needs to go down and Redeemer
with the clutch coming in at number
seven is probably the single most
oppressive operator in all of siege
blitz it's safe to say that there's
never been a time when blitzes portable
bulletproof flash banging wall of death
hasn't been a certifiable nightmare to
behold eliminates redresses tries to
come to site and then completely blinded
bandit stands no chance to Giulio
it's a clash hi hey bullet I mean really
just look at this [ __ ] this is taking
the number six spot on our list is
twitch right around when Ubisoft gave
her a second shock drone following patch
4.2 twitch not only held the f2 but had
two utility destroying silent Shin
shocking RC cars at her disposal five
health left to go sequel he's gonna tuck
himself inside of the be safe hangar
spots of HA tagged him with a twitch
throne and that's gonna be one twitch
kill here right onto the feet of
secretly at one point her drones held a
combined total of thirty shock charges
meaning that in addition to being able
to destroy every piece of utility in
sight she could theoretically down three
defenders without ever leaving her spawn
it was very stupid
one more and he's down I think to this
date which continues to be one of the
strongest attackers in the game
my problem with twitch is that I feel
like I wouldn't have a problem with
switches gun if her gadget wasn't one of
the best gadgets and in the game coming
in at number five we have glass when his
scope first got thermal vision
now while Komarov the glass cough was
intended to be a long-range sniper the
addition of thermal vision to his flip
site made him more suited for entry
fragging what do you believe the main
point of glass is or was supposed to be
a sniper perhaps like a long-distance
wall destructing hard-hitting operator
nah nah nah guys he's literally a point
man now there's also the fact that it
could see through smoke which allowed
for [ __ ] like this if they can't see me
yo glasses now over fire but he's way
broken and considering he carried three
smokes with him there was little to no
room for counter play you kind of just
had to sit there and take it
yep that was awesome get out of here
baby last one objective got him he's a
monster taking the fourth spot on our
list is none other than Nomad able to
literally knock a defender on their ass
err Japs have quickly cemented
themselves as one of the greatest post
plant perils in the game it turns out
that introducing a form of hard stun
into Rainbow six siege makes for some
pretty aggravating gameplay I've no met
thus the one thing that video games
should never do she takes away the
control from the user completely you
cannot move you cannot run you cannot
shoot you cannot breathe you cannot do
anything you cannot fight back Nomad is
literally the definition of broken in
any competitive game in addition to
becoming the bane of pro league players
everywhere a certain claim or
interaction made air jabs some of the
most broken [ __ ] in siege oh there he
goes I just washed it but that's one
yeah men taking the number three spot on
our list is the absolute terror that was
Ella upon release her scorpion had zero
recoil and carried an impossibly broken
a 50 bullet magazine almost like an
operator with 51 bullets might be broken
and let's not forget that in addition to
being a 3-speed she could deploy for
griz menthe mines which would prevent
you from sprinting and lasted for what
felt like an eternity
needless to say her wind delta was
insane her pic rate was through the roof
and she outclassed her competition in
virtually every way amela hemella coming
in at number two is an operator who's
become downright famous for how broken
he was upon release that's right we're
talking about lion now there is a sense
in which lion is objectively the most
broken operator ever released
everybody let's have some [ __ ] fun
let's have some [ __ ] fun let's have
some [ __ ] fun Wow upon activating his
EE 1d lion was able to track defenders
very silhouettes as they moved making
pre and post plant rotations absurdly
easy to counter target acquired and now
magnet knows exactly where he has to cut
off he's also getting lion also getting
yang detected by the EU 1d neo cleans
him up Raphael using the smoke and
Candela combo he's just going to push
right in they'll have some covering fire
is the artillery of glass stands in
bathroom and look at that Raphael they
will just bully the vitality sweeps into
the site eventually lion was banned from
professional play entirely while Ubisoft
went back to the drawing board
lion is an operator that we faced a
unique problem with we know that he is
overpowered and today the dev team is
ready to act on it starting next season
we will put Lyon in a competitive
quarantine which means that the players
will not be able to kick Ryan in or
eSports programs taking the top spot on
our list is perhaps the single most
despised operator in all of siege
Blackbeard perfectly you have some skin
the one whose initial concept was a
literal affront to the savagery and
skill intensity of the games shooting
mechanics we've designed our game around
headshots let's put a steel wall in
front of this guy's head that's our new
operator right now each one of his rifle
shields has 50 HP prior to patch 4.2 he
had one shield and it had 800 hp as the
game went on those who cares are called
life if that came out in year 1 season 2
but had a face shield which means you
couldn't kill him but headshots and I
was like oh I'm a terrible player I'm
gonna pick up this extremely overpowered
character and I'm gonna use as a
handicap unto that learn how to play the
game properly he was basically a shield
operator with an assault rifle any enemy
that tries to win a one-on-one firefight
with you are gonna lose hands-down the
reason why Blackbeard is as powerful as
he is right now
is that he can basically claim an entire
room by himself with not really putting
himself at any disadvantage whatsoever
to this day he remains one of the game's
biggest blunders and an atrocity from
which it barely recovered then flash
I'm gonna plant yep what I'm watching
trend right I got him
nice round well guys that's our list be
sure to like the video subscribe to the
channel and let us know in the comments
what other seeds related top 10s you
want to see see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up art Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]